تطور غير مسبوق في مسار الحرب وبعيد عن
جبهات القتال التقليديه هكذا بدا ما اعلنه
الجانب الروسي بشان توغل بري اوكراني يقع
للمره الاولى باتجاه الداخل الروسي
وتحديدا في مقاطعه بريانسك ليست المره
الاولى التي يسلط الضوء فيها على مقاطعه
لاوكرانيا خلال عام الحرب الاول اعلنت
روسيا اكثر من مره تعرض المقاطعه لقصف
اوكراني لكنها المره الاولى التي تتحدث
موسكو عن توغل بري لما وصفت بمجموعه
تخريبيه اوكرانيه وصلت الى قريه
قال حاكم مقاطعه بريانسك ان تلك المجموعه
تسللت للقريه واطلقت النار على سياره
متحركه كما احتجزت عددا من الرهائن في
متجر ومنازل هناك تحدث حكيم الولايه عن
مقتل مدني واصابه طفل ونشرت على منصات
التواصل
لوحدات روسيه تسمى نفسها الفيلق الروسيه
التطوعي وتقول انها مواليه للقوات
الاوكرانيه في المقطع يقول المسلحون انهم
بقريه اليوبتشان لتحرير ارضهم داعين
لاعلان العصيان ضد السلطات الروسيه لاحقا
اعلن جهاز امن الدوله الروسيه ان الامور
باتت تحت السيطره واكد اخراج القوميين
الاوكرانيين من مقاطعه بريانسك الى
الاراضي الاوكرانيه لكن الكرملين اعلن ان
الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين سيتراس الجمعه
اجتماعا طارئا لمجلس الامن القومي لبحث
عمليه بريانسك التي وصفها الرئيس بالحدث
الارهابي
اليوم ارتكبوا عملا ارهابيا جديدا جريمه
اخرى دخل المنطقه الحدوديه واطلقوا النار
على المدنيين رغم انها سياره مدنيه راوا
المدنيين والاطفال بداخلها واطلقوا النار
عليهم
القراءه الاوكرانيه لما وقع في بريانس نفت
بالمقابل مسؤوليه كييف وشككت في القصه
واعتبرتها محض اكاذيب روسيه
لماذا لا تكون الروايه هي ان مرتزقه
وسجناء هم من قاموا بهذا العرض الاستفزازي
او ان تكون الروايه الاخرى هي ان مجموعه
من الاستخبارات الروسيه قد ارتدت الزير
الاوكراني ووضعت شعارات صفراء واختلقت بعض
الوثائق ودعت انها اوكرانيا
بينما ترى المخابرات الاوكرانيه ان ما وقع
في بريانس استمرار للتحول في روسيا
وتنقيتها وتحريرها من ديكتاتوريه بوتين
حسب تعبيرها